Maus ago my neighbor back
I mean hips are pals here who hasn't
shaved because I can't find my charger
okay don't judge welcome to everyone
wanted a Friday video and I haven't done
one in a while
[Music]
so I didn't really have anything fun
today so I thought why not just talk
about some things because that's always
good I think my teeth look really white
sorry sorry what I would like to talk
about is I guess self advertising on
YouTube you know those comments where
people are like oh my god I know this is
super annoying at all yes it's [ __ ] s
by the way but please check out my
Minecraft videos and also I play Call of
Duty I think I nail that okay I can I
can understand because when I started my
channel
it wasn't growing fast at all I never
had a viral video no one [ __ ] knew
about my channel when I started I I
deleted most of my early early videos
because people are like wow he's changed
so [ __ ] stupid here they still
comment that no one knew who the [ __ ] I
wasn't beginning and that's okay that's
the thing with you too you shouldn't do
it to become famous or to to have become
big or whatever that's dumb you should
make it because you enjoyed doing it any
other reason is not a good one
half the fun for me is to record the
video and the other half the fun is to
read the comments and and now I can't
read the comments anymore
and they're so filled with spam they're
so filled with fake p2p accounts they're
still filled with self advertisement and
it sucks I'm it's a big problem for me
and it's it's even bringing me down
because it's ruining the fun of
something that I love to do so I'm
trying to find a solution for it I don't
know you - doesn't seem to to bother
with it
if you sell fight it out in my videos or
have done it I'm just gonna say we're
cool from here but don't [ __ ] ever do
it again
coming chop off your balls and if you
don't have balls I'll I'll attach them
and then chop them off so I'm gonna have
a competition it's been a while since we
did one basically I wanted to just
select a couple channel that I really
liked I think deserves more recognition
and I'll share them out in the next
video because I understand how it feels
like I I know what it's like to be a
channel that isn't growing well when you
wanted to I like even though you make it
for fun that doesn't mean you don't want
your channel to grow and that's that's a
lot of fun to write check the link in
the description for more information
the last one's really cool I found
that's how I found Ken way back in the
day that's how we met each other it's
funny funny how that worked out I've
been doing a lot more clouds lately
because I just have a [ __ ] ton of fun
doing that there's a lot of like a
singer player games coming out soon like
amnesia and outlast so I haven't really
felt the urge to play by myself that
much and the prop hums video you brought
along as well I understand anyway so
yeah it's good to talk about this thing
sometimes I hope this is educational for
you or that you like my r2d2 because
that's [ __ ] [ __ ] - from yungay it's
good it's gonna break I don't know why I
had this sudden impulse to buy this to
build this I mean it took it looks
simple but it took me like seven hours
and my fingers are you
yeah like it spins yeah
okay so that's all I wanted to talk
about sorry this is a little boring
friary divided by the heads that Baghdad
that uh-huh yep
that's always gross thank you for
watching please let it help me out with
the comments dude let's do something
about it I don't know why but I just
want you to understand how I'm feeling I
died anyway the custom first love you
[Music]